willkommen bei Bild der große Streit um
die Grünen sie regieren Deutschland seit
fast einem Jahr mit sie stellen die
beliebtesten Minister und gewinnen auch
weiter ordentlich Wahlen gleichzeitig
ernten Sie die härteste Kritik Sahra
Wagenknecht hält die Grünen derzeit gar
für die gefährlichste Partei im
Deutschen Bundestag der große Streit um
die Grünen hierbei Bild mit Katharina
Fegebank grüner und zweiter
Bürgermeisterin in Hamburg mit Klaus
Wiener CDU Wirtschaftsexperte im
Bundestag mit Marie-Luise Beck mit
Gründerin der Grünen langjährige
Bundestagsabgeordnete und Gründerin des
Zentrums liberale moderne weil der Mann
hartmann ist bei uns Politik begeisterte
Sportmoderatoren Legende ein Mann der
mit 74 Jahren völlig überzeugt sagt ich
habe noch nie Grün gewählt und Horst von
Buttlar ist bei uns Chef des
Wirtschaftsmagazins Kapital und Autor
des Buchs das grüne Jahrzehnt außerdem
bei uns und zugeschaltet gleich Peter
Gauweiler CSU Urgestein mehr als zehn
Jahre im Bundestag und er war auch schon
Bayern Umweltminister ihnen allen
München und hier im Studio in Berlin
herzlich willkommen bei Bild ja und eine
Frau hat besonders hart abgerechnet in
dieser Woche mit den Grünen
für mich sind die Grünen die
heuchlerischste abgehobenste verlogenste
inkompetenteste und gemessen an dem
Schaden den sie verursachen derzeit auch
die gefährlichste Partei die wir aktuell
im Bundestag haben Frau Fegebank ist
Frau Wagenknecht für die Grünen
gefährlich
also ich weiß gar nicht wie ernst man
das nehmen kann wenn es eine Partei gibt
die vom Verfassungsschutz zum
Verdachtsfall erklärt wurde das ist die
AFD meinen Augen definitiv die
gefährlichste Partei im Deutschen
Bundestag mir fallen viele andere Dinge
ein die gefährlich und schädlich sind
aber garantiert nicht die Grünen und ich
glaube da ist Frau Wagen oder Ernst eine
Million Menschen knapp haben das Video
bis jetzt gesehen sie hat sehr viel
Zustimmung dafür bekommen ich hatte für
Frau Wagenknecht für eine für eine kluge
Frau und ich weiß auch dass solche
Schritte wohl überlegt und sehr
kalkuliert sind und das halte ich für
gefährlich ja klar ich finde ihr ist der
Kompass da oder die Kompassnadel richtig
aus dem Ruder gelaufen und ich weiß
nicht ob es gut ist ihr so viel
Aufmerksamkeit zu schenkend
nein Frau Frau Wagenknecht macht mich
Dich wütend
ich weiß wo sie steht sie will die
transatlantischen Beziehungen
auseinanderbringen sie hat eine Position
in Bezug auf Einwanderung eingenommen
die bei der AFD ordentlich zu Spruch
bekommen hat und im Grunde genommen
arbeitet sie ja an so etwas wie der
gelbwestenbewegung also wir hier unten
die da oben das ist durch und durch
populistisch
da gibt es Zuspruch wie wir wissen
besonders
schief gegangen also ich würde sagen
etwas weniger Aufregung um Sarah
Wagenknecht vielleicht auch etwas
weniger Aufmerksamkeit bei den Medien in
den sozialen Medien eben längst bekommen
sie hat eine solche Reichweite mit
diesem Video erreicht habe es gerade
schon gesagt knapp eine Million Menschen
haben das gesehen wir haben eben sehr
viel Zustimmung ihr auch gewidmet Sahra
Wagenknecht bei uns heute Abend ja auch
Peter Gauweiler ein Mann den viele ja
ein Leben lang schon ein politisches
Leben lang schon als Populisten
bezeichnet haben sie wissen immer sehr
gut was auf der Straße gesprochen wird
im Bierzelt Herr Gauweiler trifft Frau
Wagenknecht da im Moment eine Stimmung
in Deutschland
ja und nein
also wenn ich das Video von der Sahra
Wagen nicht gesehen hätte
und gefragt worden wäre an was erinnert
dich die grüne Regierungspartei von
heute dann hätte ich mich gesagt die
erinnert mich an meine Junge Union
das sind die eigentlich
systemstabilisierten
Zeitgeist
adäquatesten
die politischen Boden am meisten
bestimmensten
auf der anderen Seite ist natürlich der
Hinweis auf die Gefahr nicht ganz zu
Unrecht wir hatten früher die Gefahr bei
den Grünen immer gesehen von da wo sie
herkommen aus der außerparlamentarischen
Opposition die ja die alte
Bundesrepublik
umwandeln wollten die damals da unter
den Bildern von Massenmördern über
unsere Straßen gezogen sind und in ganz
bestimmten Punkten ab 1970
hatte Henry Kissinger das Gefühl und
geäußert das in zehn Jahren ganz
Deutschland und Europa kommunistisch
würde das waren ihre Anfänge
das Bild der Grünen ist also
zwiegespalten aber fühlen sie sich da
kurze Nachfrage Herr Gauweiler an Herrn
Strauß an Franz-Josef Strauß erinnert
der immer gewarnt hat vor den Grünen und
jetzt übernimmt das nicht mehr die CSU
macht nicht der Söder sondern räumt die
Wagenknecht ab
nee Strauß hatte auch grüne die er
mochte z.B erinnere ich mich gut dass er
eine der
urkolleginnen von Ihnen Frau Beck die
Frau Antje Vollmer mehrfach nach Bayern
eingeladen hatte
und sie hatten eine Reihe von sehr guten
und
interessanten Gesprächen woraus man auch
sieht dass es bei den Grünen andere und
nicht so auf das totalitäre angelegte
Persönlichkeiten gibt
wenn wir das jetzt zusammenfassen
wir können gerne über Differenzen reden
Herr Gauweiler aber den Grünen
totalitary totalitäres zuzuschreiben ist
sowas von Abbruch mal zurückweisen
wir bauen uns doch wechselseitig nichts
zu erzählen wir kennen uns seit
Jahrzehnten aus der Ferne
ihre Gruppierung kommt aus den
car-gruppen und wenn es in Deutschland
etwas totalitäres gab da schauen Sie
sich mal ein bisschen um in ihrer
Umgebung dann wartest diese Bewegung ich
liebe ihn ja gar nicht böse deshalb aber
wenn man selber so viel über
Vergangenheitsbewältigung redet dann
soll man doch da offen und sie waren
ganz unverstellt sein
in den Bundestag gezogen sind finden
sich da wieder nein ich kam immer aus
dem Freund in Baden-Württemberg
Winfried Kretschmann andere es war immer
unser Grundsatz die Politik muss
dialogisch sein deswegen ist ja
Kretschmann jetzt auch so gefährlich
zu gefährlich ja war doch auch in der
karl-gruppe in der maxistischen Gruppe
ganz zu Anfang ja aber wer war Ende der
60er Anfang der 70er Jahre doch auch
sagen ja aber doch ich mache mit heute
überhaupt
an die Vergangenheit und sprechen über
die
gründepartei heute die Regierungspartei
ist die heute seit fast einem Jahr eben
mitregiert in ganz Deutschland im Bund
nämlich und über die jetzt bei
Wagenknecht gesagt hat die Partei ist
gefährlich und das macht sie an Inhalten
fest an der Energiepolitik vor allen
Dingen ist das alles Quatsch was die
Linke sagt
also zuerst als ich das gehört habe ich
gesagt hey Moment also die gefährlichste
Partei ist die AFD die dem Bundestag
sitzt und dann hat Herr Bartsch sie
zurechtgewiesen und hat das ebenso
gesehen und dann habe ich mir gedacht
wenn Bartsch der Wagenknecht in die
Parade fährt dann muss er doch was dran
sein oder habe ich noch mal nachgedacht
und bin zu dem Schluss gekommen die AFD
ist nicht gefährlich in dem Sinne weil
sie nicht in der Regierung sitzt sie
sitzt in keiner Landesregierung es ist
in keine Bundesregierung und das wird
hoffentlich lange so bleiben also ist
die Partei vor der ich mir Sorgen mache
ich würde gefährlich nicht sagen aber es
ist die Partei
die mir am
schlimmsten den Tag versorgen
weil sie eine Partei ich sag mal so eine
lehrezimmer Partei ist die nur reguliert
dir nur Befehl die Ratschläge erteilt
die ich mag es jetzt mal am Beispiel
fest wenn herr Kretschmann mir erzählen
will dass ich mich am besten mit dem
Waschlappen waschen soll und dass ich
nur ein Zimmer heizen soll jetzt machen
wir die aktuelle
Energiekrise und
in der Innenstadt nur noch mit
lastenfahrrädern gefahren werden soll
also alles das was uns zurückführt eine
die Industrialisierung die durch die
Energiepolitik zwangsläufig kommt und da
sage ich das war nicht der Sinn meines
Lebens dass ich mit 74 im nächsten
Jahrzehnt wieder dorthin komme wo ich
herkomme einmal selbstkritisch dazu viel
erhobene Zeigefinger zu viel
Vorschriften zu viel Verbote in ihrer
Partei durch ihre Partei
also ich bin immer wieder total erstaunt
das hat sich ja offenbar vor 20 30
Jahren irgendetwas festgesetzt dass
jetzt immer wieder reflexartiger
vorgeholt wird wenn es darum geht das
grüne die ihr in 11 Ländern und
wahrscheinlicher bald in dem zwölften
Bundesland mit Regierungsverantwortung
tragen seit gut einem Jahr und ich bin
sehr froh darüber dass die Grünen als
Stimme der Vernunft in dieser
Bundesregierung am Ruder mit sitzen in
einer noch nie da gewesenen
Krisensituation Verantwortung tragen
russland hat die Ukraine angegriffen wir
sind in einer Krisensituation die sich
ganz erheblich ausgewirkt hat natürlich
auf die Frage von Energieversorgung wir
haben jetzt dramatisch vor Augen geführt
bekommen was eine Energieabhängigkeit
bedeutet für uns und das ist dann
Antworten geben muss und zwar nicht nur
auf der Frage wo kommt die Energie her
und wie können wir sie preiswert halten
und wie ist die Versorgungssicherheit
gewährleistet sondern was kann auch
wirklich jeder Einzelne tun also
Stichwort Energie sparen ich kann das
verstehen dass man sagt habe ich keine
Lust mich über Waschlappen kommt und
warum ist da nicht herkommen ganz genau
gerade dabei zum einen neben dem
Energiesparen herzuleiten woher kommt
die Energie und wie kommen wir vor allem
möglichst schnell dahin wo wir 16 Jahre
geschlafen haben vor allen Dingen aus
dem Wahlkampf rausgeholt von den Grünen
und der hieß es sie erleben ein grünes
Wirtschaftswunder mit den Grünen jetzt
sagen viele
das ist mittlerweile blaues oder Böses
Wirtschaftswunder
in der Tat also die wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung ist eindeutig nach unten
gerichtet das hängt mit der Energiekrise
zusammen und es hängt natürlich auch mit
dem Angebot zusammen das viel zu gering
ist und Habeck hat gesagt alle Optionen
müssen auf dem Tisch das mit den Grünen
zusammen
alle Optionen müssen auf dem Tisch und
was wir gerade jetzt in der
kernkraftwerksdebatte wieder erlebt
haben ist das eben nicht alle Optionen
auf dem Tisch kommen wir haben im März
einen prüfermarkt bekommen der die Tinte
nicht wert war auf die er geschrieben
war der wurde in zwei Wochen
zusammengeschustert er wurde in
kürzester Zeit wiederlegt dann gab es
einen Stresstest der heute auch immer
wieder gerne zitiert das vernünftig dann
greifen wir genau das Beispiel auch von
der Wiener ist das vernünftig Frau Beck
Frau Fegebank jetzt zu sagen die
Energiekrise ist im Grunde im nächsten
April zu Ende ab da können wir dann die
Atomkraftwerke in Ruhe abschalten schon
erstaunlich wenn über 30 Jahre hinweg
und jedes Jahr stärker Deutschland
abhängig gemacht worden ist fast
ausschließlich von
und zwar sind wir gewarnt worden wir
sind gewarnt worden von Polen
wir sind gewarnt worden von den USA dann
ist gesagt worden die USA wollen ja nur
ihr Schiefergas verkaufen es gab viele
Warnungen es wurde in Nord Stream 1
gemacht es wurde sogar nach dem Russland
sein Gesicht gezeigt hatte und die Krim
annektiert worden war wir wollen
trotzdem gucken dass wir nicht zu weit
und zu lange zurückkommen wir müssen
jetzt Kommando ist es ist tatsächlich
bei diesem Auftrag kann man da ist jetzt
die wichtige Frage der Sie sich jetzt in
der Bundesregierung stellen müssen tun
sie alles um den Geldbeutel der
deutschen zu entlasten und haben viele
im Moment den Eindruck es wird nicht
alles gemacht es wird nicht alles getan
um die deutsche Industrie zu retten sie
glauben weiter Herr von Buttlar an das
grüne Wirtschaftswunder haben sich mit
ihrem Buch diesem grünen Jahrzehnt
gewidmet das ist gerade auf den Markt
gekommen sie haben das Buch aber schon
vor Krieg angefangen hat sie es im
Grunde schon überholt das Buch und wir
erleben kein grünes Jahrzehnt mit seinen
Einzel indem wir wieder Kohlekraft
brauchen indem wir wieder Kernkraft
brauchen nein das hat sich nicht
überholt und dieser Begriff ist auch
nicht politisch gemeint sondern wenn man
sich die Aufgaben anguckt die wir bis
2030 machen müssen wirtschaftlich dann
ist das ein Umbau unserer Wirtschaft
unser Energieversorgung und eigentlich
hatte Deutschland einen guten Plan würde
ich mal sagen das war ziemlich
ausbruchstabiert in diesem
Koalitionsvertrag drin da standen die
ganzen Zahlen drin das war so drin und
dieser Krieg hat jetzt ist in jeder
Hinsicht eine Katastrophe für
Deutschland ist eine doppelte
Katastrophe er sendet bei jedem Land
Schockwellen durch die Energieversorgung
für Deutschland ist es ein spezielles
Problem Gas sollte unsere
Brückentechnologie sein und diese Brücke
ist zusammengebrochen wir wollten noch
40 bis 50 Gaskraftwerke bauen denn wie
kriegen es nicht so schnell hin mit den
Erneuerbaren das heißt zurück zur
Kohlekraft zurückzukehren deswegen wenn
es jetzt zwei kalte Winter zwei härter
glaube ich werden wir die Kohle springt
immer in die Lücke seine Katastrophe im
besten Fall muss man sagen und da habe
ich noch mal wirklich alle gefragt auch
BSF und ThyssenKrupp die Strategien
laufen weiter ist ja nicht so dass die
Gründerinnen und Gründer jetzt aufhören
ihre Start-ups zu machen also die machen
ja alle weiter die Strategien von
Unternehmen laufen bis 2030 also
kurzfristig Katastrophe mittelfristig
darf man das Ziel aber nicht aus dem aus
den Augen verlieren sie in ihrem Buch so
ein bisschen hinweg und sagen
kurzfristig Katastrophe aber das
bedeutet ja erstmal sie werden den
Menschen jetzt sagen müssen dass sie ja
massenhaft pleite gehen sie werden
Menschen sagen müssen dass sie jetzt
ihren Job verlieren und da hilft es
nicht am Horizont
2015 natürlich tatsächlich dieser Winter
ist den Menschen näher als 2030 oder
2050 und das ist auch ganz natürlich das
ist menschlich und deswegen müssen wir
jetzt aber das Ziel bleibt trotzdem
richtig und ich glaube das was Frau
Wagenknecht sagt ich meine die hat ja
ein feines Gespür für die Ängste und
Nöte der Menschen aber trotzdem ist es
das ist ja quatsch mit Soße muss man
einfach sagen trotzdem also was sie da
gesagt hat dass die gefährlichste Partei
sind okay also ich ich glaube da
projizieren sich im Moment viele Sorgen
und Ängste auf die Grünen die Grünen
machen viele Fehler aber dass sie jetzt
für alles schuld sind also für die
Katastrophen sehr Energieversorgung sind
die Grünen nicht Schuld man was man ihn
vorwerfen kann oder der dieser Regierung
eine sehr viel robustere Antwort ab März
also hätte man gesagt Deutschland wird
alles tun also drei Sachen wir werden
Kernkraft so lange laufen lassen wie wir
es für nötig halten egal offen lassen
Kohle muss leider in die Lücke und
drittens wir werden ab sofort unsere
eigene Gasvorkommen prüfen nur diese
drei Worten weil hätte auch hätte den
magenografie entgegensteht weil noch
ideologiestärke laufen weiter oder
werden angefahren also auch
Kohlekraftwerke die schon passiert auch
ja aber auch von neuen Brennstäben
beispielsweise also ich kann den Grünen
in der Regierung weder im Bund noch in
den Ländern ein ich kann ihnen keinen
Vorwurf machen weil genau das passiert
was eben auf waldemar Hartmann als
Vorwurf in den Raum gestellt hat nämlich
das zum der oben eine Zeigefinger und
zum zweiten
ideologische oder parteipolitisch Dinge
blockiert oder durchgebracht werden das
Gegenteil ist doch der Fall also wenn
ich mir angucke wo wir entscheiden dass
Kohlekraftwerke weiterlaufen dass wir
über lng-terminals schwimmende
lng-terminals sprechen die aus Ländern
kommen von denen wir vielleicht auch
nicht sagen würden das sind jetzt die
Demokratien mit denen wir gerne
Geschäfte machen das sind doch alles
Dinge die wir auf aufs Gleis gesetzt
haben die wir jetzt alle gerade bewegen
ohne wir machen schon so und wir haben
doch jetzt die drei bestehenden AKWs bis
April 23
ist doch der Witz den Rest an Ideologie
übersetzt sich jetzt mit meinen Worten
den müsst ihr ertragen naja aber das die
Entscheidung die wir jetzt gerade
bekommen haben zu den Kernkraftwerken
erstmal kam es ja nicht von den Grünen
sondern der Bundeskanzler hat Machtwort
gesprochen glauben Sie mir ist das so
war ganz kurz glauben Sie dass das ja
glauben sie die Geschichte
Geschichte dieses machtworts also war
das so sie sind doch veräppelt worden
auf dem Parteitag jetzt ganz ehrlich das
war doch vorher das war doch abgekartet
vorher und da habe ich es doch nicht
durch den Parteitag gegangen ohne zu
wissen was 24 Stunden danach passiert
eine Zuschreibung zu Robert Habeck die
einfach nicht zu ihnen als Person passt
das muss man einfach sagen ja finde ich
vollkommen finde ich ungerechtfertigt
und der Habeck ist ja tatsächlich
unterwegs
international in dem Versuch diese
dramatische Situation die entstanden ist
so abzufedern dass wir von verschiedenen
Lieferanten jetzt aus der Klemme aber
ganz konkret noch mal zu dem Machtwort
weil weil sie gesagt haben das passt gar
nicht zu Herrn Harbeck das heißt sie
glauben die Geschichte dass er durch den
Parteitag gegangen ist auf dem sie
natürlich auch fahren pflegebet sie
waren nicht vor Ort haben den aber dann
aus Hamburg viel Erfolg dass er durch
diesen Parteitag gegangen ist die ganze
Zeit gesagt hat das dritte Atomkraftwerk
nämlich in Niedersachsen das wird da
wird die Laufzeit nicht verlängert und
24 Stunden danach stimmt er dem
Machtwort von es gab Unstimmigkeiten in
der Koalition und es gab dann die
Notwendigkeit schnell zu entscheiden
also es war ja immer klar dass die FDP
geklärt einen anderen Kurs wollte und
das war klar dass das auch irgendwann
aufgelöst hat
unser sparen müssen
auch ein Gespür für die Größenordnung
bewahren ja und wir haben einen
unglaublichen Energiebedarf wir sind
Industrieland und da wer ist wirklich
gut gewesen wenn wir so wie andere
Länder das auch machen Schweden als
Beispiel wenn wir gesagt hätten die drei
Kernkraftwerke die wir haben und
idealerweise auch die drei die wir
wieder ans Netz bringen können die
nutzen wir jetzt so lange bis die
Erneuerbaren ausgebaut ist ich bin ja
selbst auch ein Anhänger davon dass wir
die Erneuerbaren ausbauen aber wir haben
einen immensen Energiebedarf und das was
bislang gemacht wurde das reicht eben
nicht das sehen wir doch täglich an den
Börsenpreisen für Gas das sehen wir die
ein bisschen zurückgekommen sind aber
immer noch extrem hoch sind da sehen wir
an den Strompreisen wir müssen ein wir
müssen eine Strategie entwickeln wo wir
sagen was brauchen wir den letzten zehn
Jahre und was brauchen wir da auch an
Angebot für die zehn Jahre und da kann
ich immer das narrativ kommen hätten wir
mehr ausgebaut hätten wir das Problem
jetzt nicht sondern wir hatten genau das
gleiche Problem jetzt Schaden die Grünen
ihrer Meinung nach der Wirtschaft das
ist die Diskussion in der Weigerung
jetzt tatsächlich jedes Angebot zu
nutzen ja Biomethan Gas kann man noch
dazu fügen die Kernkraftwerke auch
heimisches Gas ja Stichwort Tracking es
gab eine Expertenkommission die ganz
klar gesagt hat Tracking heute ist nicht
mehr das was wir vor 20 Jahren gesehen
haben alles das wird nicht angepackt aus
ideologischen Gründen und wenn sie mit
Unternehmen sprechen mit kleineren
Unternehmen mit dem mittelständischen
Unternehmen die haben immense Probleme
und die zahlen die Zeche dieser Politik
aber der Vorwurf ist ja Hartmann dass
die Grünen der wirtschaftsschaden dass
die Grünen jetzt nicht alles tun würden
um den Gaspreis um den Strompreis vor
allen Dingen zu senken
ich mit doch ich gehe damit schon einig
dass sie das tun dass sie das auch mit
Herrn Gedanken verfolgen aber es passt
so viel nicht zusammen also wenn er
Habeck nach Katha fährt das ja seit
Monaten oder Jahren verteufelt wird
wegen der Arbeiter Geschichten für die
Stadien für den Stadionbau war der
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft
doch jetzt mit dem nichts zu tun was ich
jetzt sage ich stimme die
nicht die Stimme dem ja zu zurecht wird
das beklagt zu Recht so
Habeck springt in diesem Fall weil die
Grünen das ja auch tun zu Recht tun das
Anklagen fährt dorthin um ein Deal
möglichen Deal einzufädeln mit Katar und
macht einen Hofknicks er springt also
über seine Ideologie aber
das klingt nicht über seine Ideologie
wenn es um die Verlängerung von drei
existierenden Atomkraftwerken in
Deutschland geht da muss er durch den
Parteitag und wir wurden schlicht
untergreifend verarscht es kann mir doch
keine erzählen dass er das nicht wusste
dass 24 Stunden später der Scholz sagt
ich werde jetzt von meiner
kompetenzgebrauch machen die wussten das
das waren die und der wusste dass der
halbwegs sonst nicht durchkommt kurz
zusammenfassen sie müssen beide tun
jetzt so als ob die tiefgreifende Krise
die wir haben die durch den Krieg kommt
und die kommt weil wir wie kein anderes
Land aber dann können wir uns einige
hier in der Runde die Verantwortung ist
ganz wesentlich bei denen die vorher
regiert haben jetzt durch ein einziges
Atomkraftwerk aus der Welt geschaffen
wird und das ist großer Teil aber das
war auch nicht das was Herr Hartmann
gesagt hat war die ganze Zeit auf dieser
eigenen kraftfrage vorbereitet und
Tracking ist auch noch die Frage kommt
dazu man muss in der Tat jetzt zu sehr
unangenehmen Regime gehen aber sie haben
nicht diese Macht die wir Russland
gegeben haben dass sie ein ganzes Land
für die Ukraine zerstören und das ist
ein großer Unterschied und er ist nicht
gemacht worden von den Regierungen
dass es ihnen als grüne weniger wehtut
den Bückling dort bei den Scheichs zu
machen also bei ihren eigenen Schatten
es ist eine Zuschreibung die nicht in
Ordnung ist das ist einfach nicht in
Ordnung zu sagen ein Minister Habeck hat
Hamburg
das Geschäft mit Katar zu machen als zu
Hause die restideologie abzuräumen und
die neuen Brennstäbe beispielsweise zu
besorgen ja das ist ein riesen Thema mit
den neuen Brennstäben deshalb haben wir
haben wir gesagt wir gehen diesen Weg
wir verläng die laufenden AKWs auf April
23 und dann aber auch Ende
weil diverse Gesetze dafür auch hätten
geändert werden müssen
verfassungsrechtlich ist völlig unklar
ob das funktioniert und wir tun das was
nur wendig ist wir tun jetzt das was
notwendig ist um unser Verantwortung
gerecht zu werden mit entsprechender mit
entsprechender Versorgungssicherheit
nicht nur über diesen Winter zu kommen
sondern auch in der nächsten Jahre
ganz kurz die Frage ist die auch Herr
Wiener aufgeworfen hat Schaden die
Grünen aktuell in dieser schwierigen
Wirtschaftslage zunehmend der Wirtschaft
oder tun sie alles um den Gaspreis zu
senken um unser Energieangebot
tatsächlich zu vergrößern
also ich glaube dass wir Ursache und
Wirkung nicht verwechseln dürfen die
Grünen haben ja keinen heel aus ihrer
Meinung gemacht
dass sie sich da als als als
restriktenbriefe Kraft
verstehen und dass sie so sind wie sie
sind die eigentliche Gefahr für
Deutschland ist die Infektion die die
großen Volksparteien erlitten haben
SPD und manchmal noch mehr CDU und
machen wir sogar die CSU spielen
umgekehrte Grünen als ob sie selber mit
erfunden haben übernehmen die Sprache
übernehmen die ganzen Faxen das ganze
blöde Getue das kein Mensch eigentlich
mehr hören kann und sagen
wir machen von Gender bis Windkraft
alles Dinge von denen die einzelnen nie
überzeugt sind und wenn man sie darauf
ansprechen sagt man macht oder es auch
mit dir alles müssen wir das wird nicht
verlangt das ist jetzt die große Mode
der beteiligen wir uns auch ich mache da
den Grünen nicht so den Vorwurf die sind
halt so ein und jeder Mensch hat es
recht nach seiner politischen
Überzeugung oder Überzeugung Veranlagung
zu leben und sich zu äußern was mich
ankotzt ist die Art und Weise wie
eigentlich seit 20 Jahren dieser das was
man allgemein grüner Mainstream nennt
von den großen Volksparteien also von
dem Parteien die ja in einem ganz
anderen Trend
Deutschland wieder aufgebaut hat der
erste atomenmaler in Garching der ist
von dem spd-ministerpräsidenten eröffnet
worden wir waren früher stolz darauf
dass wir die Wasserwege gebaut haben
wir haben in Bayern sie haben es vorhin
kurz erwähnt das erste Umweltministerium
der Welt aufgebaut und wir haben jetzt
eine Art
sorry das nachäffens die ich irgendwie
unangenehm empfinde aber das kann man
jetzt mit gefährlich nicht den Grünen
Anlassen
aber
wir haben jetzt sogar also stop wir
haben jetzt sogar letzten Sonntag hat
ein grüner eine Wahl gewonnen das ist
der Palme ja
in seiner Heimatstadt aus dem könnte
noch was werden also den könnte ich mal
durchaus vorstellen
kann ne ähm wo auch immer es ist ja
alles in Änderung über den sprechen wir
gleich aber der Vorwurf steht im Raum
gar nicht gegen die Grünen von Herrn
Gauweiler sondern für den Moment sie
sind alle viel zu groß gewesen
er macht eine imkerstand auf und am
nächsten Tag umarmte den Baum also Söder
ist ihn zu grün geworden ja natürlich
und alles geht doch in die Richtung also
Herr Günther in Schleswig-Holstein
also ich möchte auch das nicht immer
grün nennen sondern ich möchte auch mal
den Begriff Nachhaltigkeit hier
einführen ja und ich glaube das ist
wirklich gut ist und wir sind alle
inzwischen ja der Meinung dass wir
nachhaltig aber das ist nicht das was
spricht ein grünen Mainstream an er hat
das Gendern angesprochen sie laufen
hinterher sagt der Gauweiler
er hat den
Atomausstieg genannt das war ja im
übrigen beschlossen von der von der von
den Grünen gehört dass sie gesagt haben
wir sind dagegen ja ich meine das was
das
identitätsstiftende Thema für die Grünen
überhaupt zu sagen dass die Abhängigkeit
die sich ergeben hat von russischem Gras
nur einer Partei zugeschrieben werden
kann ist natürlich völliger Unsinn ja
man hat ganz klar gesagt wir wollen auch
von Seiten der Grünen raus aus der
Atomkraft wir wollen Kohle nicht wegen
CO2 wir wollen lng-gas nicht erinnere
mich der frühere Präsident Trump hat mal
angeboten LNG Gas wollten wir nicht weil
es gefrecktes Glas ist weil wir es
runter kühlen müssen weil wir 6000
Kilometer über den Atlantik fahren
müssen und dann gab es immer wieder
Bürgerbewegungen wo auch viele Gründe
dabei waren Lotte mal backyard wenn
Trassen gebaut werden sollten und so
weiter also die Grünen müssen sich an
der Stelle auch wirklich mal ehrlich
machen dass sie natürlich auch ein
gerüttelt Maß Mitverantwortung für die
energiepolitische Situation
das ist der Vorbau von von Herrn
Gauweiler sie schmiegen sich an ja
überhaupt nicht an also ich bin nur noch
mal sagen dass wir viele viele Jahre
Zeit verloren haben
in der Umgestaltung unserer Wirtschaft
und in der Energieversorgung und das die
haben wir verloren weil man gemeint hat
man könnte sich aufs Gas auf eine
billige Energieträger zurückziehen das
ist einfach das hat ja Angela Merkel
hat einen Anteil der erneuerbaren
Energien am Primärenergieverbrauch an
der ist von 2005 bis 2020 von 5 auf 20%
gestiegen das ist mehr das ist mehr als
die gesamte EU das ist mehr als die OECD
das ist mehr als die Welt wir sind da
ganz vorne weg dieses narrativ das
nichts passiert ist stimmt so einfach
nicht es ist unglaublich viel passiert
mehr als in anderen Ländern ich bin auch
viel europäisch unterwegs gewesen das
können sie so nicht sagen Herr von
Buttler wir streiten über die
Wirtschaftspolitik und sie blicken
voller Optimismus in die Zukunft trotz
trotz trotz allem ja allzu viele findet
man in dieser Zeit nicht die genau
diesen Optimismus weitertragen wann
werden wir die Früchte ernten dessen was
wir mit ihrer Meinung nach säen müssen
also ich habe mich intensiv mit dem
Thema beschäftigt weil es ist ja wir
reden immer nur also es ist sehr viel
Projektion findet gerade statt dass die
Grünen sind offenbar jetzt an und allen
Schuld ich glaube wenn die Grünen Weg
wären hätten noch die gleichen Probleme
aber es ist nicht so wir haben einfach
zwei grüne heute in der Runde sitzen und
wollen mit der Regierungspartei die
Grünen auch wirklich Art diskutieren
kann tatsächlich ich glaube wir haben
seit März einfach Zeit verloren wir
haben den Sommer verbracht mit
duschtipps und man stoßlüftet und das
hat aber auch allen Parteien es hätte
auch der FDP nicht passieren dürfen dass
wir sehenden Auges äh Fleischer und
Bäckereien hier pleite gehen lassen das
war doch mit Ansage dass diese
Volkswirtschaft mit einem vier bis
fünffachen Gaspreis nicht zu fahren ist
optimistisch bin ich wenn ich Menschen
treffe die trotz allem nach Lösung
suchen also ganz viele natürlich und die
machen alle weiter befürchten sie
zumindest jetzt vorübergehend eine Art
die Industrialisierung das ja böses Wort
schlimmes Wort also sagen wir diese
Gefahr ist tatsächlich dafür Deutschland
diese berühmt also Chemie Stahl Zement
wir haben das noch alles Automobilbau
und das wird tatsächlich also einen
Umbauplan der ohnehin ehrgeizig war es
war ja ohnehin schwierig ihr wollt ja
zwei bis dreimal schneller werden und
wir können ja nicht so tun als ob wir
das fünfmal so schnell werden können Sie
mal die Stimmung bei den Unternehmen auf
den Punkt
eindeutig ich würde mal ich würde mal
sagen die das muss man in drei Teile
teilen am Anfang war sehr viel
Aufbruchstimmung Deutschland hat er
endlich einen Plan und die
Wirtschaftsmarkt Planbarkeit es war
davor Stillstand dann kam eine
honeymoon-phase möchte ich mal nennen da
wurde oder wird immer noch Robert Robert
Habeck sehr geschätzt die haben gesagt
also alle Unternehmerinnen und
Unternehmer die ich gesprochen habe der
hört wirklich zu das ist auch ein
anderer Ton das ist auch ein anderes
Niveau bei auch bei den Krisen stehen
und Kanzleramt sehr gut vorbereitet auch
Olaf Scholz hat er so rund moderiert und
jetzt die letztens acht Wochen große
Enttäuschung doch auch eine Entfremdung
also ich glaube mit der gasumlage und
diesen Insolvenz da hat er sich einfach
verheddert das heißt
das heißt auch interessant das heißt
aber jetzt nicht dass der Ofen aus ist
glaube ich immer sozusagen in der
Metapher zu bleiben es gibt nach wie vor
ein eine gute Sprache und Verständigung
zwischen der Wirtschaft in den grünen
das ist ein altes Klischee dass die
einen die anderen bekämpfen würde ich
sagen aber der Ofen ist bei immer mehr
Firmen aus Roger Bank und wenn er der
Chef der Kapital ja wenn Herr von
Buttler hier das Wort die
installisierung sogar in den Mund nimmt
und sagt na na also das geht schon
vorübergehend zumindest in die Richtung
dann ist es schon alarmiert das ist eine
sehr angespannte Lage sehr
besorgniserregend ich kriege das mit
Hamburg Stadtstaat wir haben sehr engen
Austausch wirtschaftsdialog sowohl mit
den großen Industrieunternehmen
Mittelstand Handwerksbetrieben uns
erreichen diese Nachrichten täglich aber
es ist immer noch geprägt von einem
gewissen Optimismus wir kriegen das doch
zusammen irgendwie hin und die Hoffnung
auch in Richtung Bundesregierung und
dann flankiert durch die jeweiligen
Landesregierung ist da dass wir jetzt
nach dieser
Kapriole der
gaspreisumlage dass wir jetzt doch auf
dem richtigen Kurs sind mit der Bremse
bzw dem im Europa
Land und dass wir da europäisch wirklich
brauchen
Frau Beck und deswegen Sorgen wir uns
natürlich ganz besonders um unsere
Preise ich will nur noch mal sagen es
gibt einen Krieg und zwar einen großen
Krieg der nicht nur die Ukraine betrifft
sondern der unser gesamte insbesondere
Europa erschüttert gegen guckt schauen
Sie mal nach England neben dem brexit
unsere Regierung nicht würde ich sagen
ich hoffe also insofern ist das wirklich
etwas was wir auch sagen müssen es ist
Krieg und die Folgen dieses Krieges
kommen bei uns an das muss man sehr
deutlich sagen und insofern ist übrigens
Verständnis noch sie leben in Leipzig
sehr langer Zeit schon seit drei Jahren
wir frieren müssen für diesen Krieg das
viele zumindest in Deutschland werden
frieren müssen in diesem Winter für
diesen kann nur darüber reden wie ich
mit Leuten das meine ich in dem Fall ist
sagt man so gern beim Bäcker oder beim
Metzger gibt's ja nicht mehr so viele
und ich hoffe es werden noch ein paar
kaputt gehen die glaubt man nichts mehr
und wenn ich hier das hohe Lied über
Robert Habeck den heiligen Robert höre
also dort höre ich nicht das Erzählte
reicht sondern das Erreichte zählt und
da ist bisschen nichts auf dem Konto
eingegangen die haben richtig große
sorgen welche eine Bäckerei lebt
nicht für 150 verkaufen weil da kein
Mensch mehr kommt das habe ich ja nicht
erfunden die haben einfach Angst dass
sie die Energiekosten nicht mehr zahlen
können und das ist nicht die einzige
Sorge diese haben aber das ist übrigens
mit sehr großen Programmen
gegengesteuert worden ist und die
Herausforderung war ja auch das glaube
ich früher schneller hätte man es machen
ja ich würde mal Sondervermögen das sind
sonderschulden ja natürlich das ist halt
so das ist so wenn man nach dem Krise
Konjunkturprogramm für die AFD weil die
Leute wissen doch dass sie das
zurückzahlen müssen und die AFD kommt
mit sirenengeheulen und sagt müsste
alles zurückzahlen die machen eure
Zukunft kaputt eure Kinder müssen sich
und wir deswegen in Sachsen laufen denen
die Leute nach ja und Putin ist
derjenige der will dass die AFD stärker
wird denn dieses Abschalten des Gases
ist ja genau auch
Krieg und das Verhältnis der Grünen zu
Waffenlieferung das vertiefen wir gleich
nach einer ganz kurzen Pause gleich
zurück hier bei
zurück bei Wild die richtigen Fragen wir
streiten heute über die Grünen und das
tun wir mit den Grünen und wir streiten
über deren Verhältnis zum Krieg zu
Waffenlieferungen in die Ukraine Frau
Beck sie gehörten zu den
Gründungsmitgliedern der Grünen sind
eine der ersten Abgeordneten gewesen die
für die Grünen eben in den Bundestag
gezogen sind wenn wir wir sehen die
Bilder noch mal von damals wenn wir
dieser jungen Abgeordneten damals gesagt
hätten dass die Grünen für
Waffenlieferung für mehr Waffenlieferung
für panzerlieferung in die Ukraine sind
was wäre die Antwort gewesen das hätte
ich damals nicht für Möglichkeiten weil
ich tatsächlich den naiven Glauben hatte
dass keine Waffen einzusetzen immer die
beste Lösung ist ich bin heute
erschrocken über mich selber und frage
mich warum ich als Mensch aus
Deutschland wo der Nationalsozialismus
mit Hilfe von Waffen niedergerungen
werden
Ängste und mit vielen vielen Opfern
weshalb dieser Gedanke nicht in meinem
Kopf war und dass es eben hieß zu Recht
heißt nie wieder Krieg aber zu Recht
auch heißt Schutz der Opfer und das habe
ich dann in Bosnien verstanden und das
war
1993 Frau Beck die heute sagt sie findet
sich naiv im Rückblick Frau Fegebank
wenn Sie diese Lebensgeschichte von Frau
Beck hören sind sie heute noch naiv und
würden sie die Grünen heute noch als
Friedensaktivisten bezeichnen sicherlich
Friedensaktivisten aber ich finde das
sehr beeindruckend ich kenne die
Geschichte von Marie-Luise
Tränen nicht aber ich
habe unglaublich viel Respekt
vor dieser Entwicklung vor allem vor
dieser Erkenntnis
das gerade in der jetzigen Situation die
Waffenlieferungen
erforderlich notwendig sind
um den Opfern um denjenigen die
angegriffen wurden die Möglichkeit zu
geben sich zu verteidigen ihr
Territorium zu verteidigen ihre Familien
zu verteidigen ihr Leben zu verteidigen
und deshalb war für mich die
Entscheidung so hart das klingen mag die
war für mich sonnenklar zu sagen
natürlich müssen wir dem zustimmen nicht
nur dem Sondervermögen sondern auch
jetzt der Lieferung von schweren Waffen
die Grünen die so aus voller Überzeugung
jetzt für Waffenlieferungen streiten
gibt es keine Alternative da hat man aus
ihrer Sicht
im Moment glaube ich nicht weil der
Krieg ist so in vollem Gange dass der
nicht von heute auf morgen storniert
werden kann und besteht die Hoffnung ich
glaube aber dass wir da auch einer
gewissen Propaganda unterliegen die
Bildzeitung tut da einiges dazu ich sehe
immer zur Chance eine russische Panzer
ich sehe die Ukraine hat neu gewonnen
ich glaube das nicht so recht weil ich
nicht dran glauben kann dass die
russische Armee so schwach ist wie sie
dargestellt wird deswegen müssen da
Waffen hin aber ich habe mich schon sehr
gewundert wie wie hyperaktiv plötzlich
die Grünen wurden also Anton Hofreiter
habe ich in der Zeit wo ich in Berlin
gewohnt habe gesehen wir im
dreiteileranzug auf dem Radl durch
Berlin-Mitte gefahren ist jeder
Waffengattung mittlerweile Pazifist war
aber Pazifismus ist so lange sehr edel
bis die erste Bombe fällt und für mich
heißt der plötzlich der Panzer Toni weil
er der Vertreter derjenigen bei den
Grünen ist die das for die
Waffenlieferungen forcieren weil wir
eine Menge
Menschenrecht
das heute die Grüne Partei vertreten das
hier auch Frau Fegebank und Frau Beck
fehlte sie im Moment an der Alternative
dazu
also ich glaube dass der Bundeskanzler
Scholz Recht hat von dem ich heute in
der Zeitung gelesen habe nicht
Bundeskanzler Stolz der
Fraktionsvorsitzende Mütze nicht der die
Außenministerin doch gemahnt oder
gebeten hat
nie vor lauter
kriegswaffenlieferungspropaganda nicht
die Diplomatie zu vergessen generell
brauchen wir in der Ukraine
jetzt keine Winston Churchill Lösung
sondern eine Henry Kissinger Aktion und
das könnte und müsste von Deutschland
als besonderen Verantwortungsträger
kommen
ich habe was die Grünen angeht ihre
Waffenlosigkeit nie abgenommen und was
Frau wegschafft ist die halbe Wahrheit
und die ganze Lüge die Grünen haben als
Apo Leute massiv mit der Parole Sieg im
Volkskrieg angefangen ich habe wir sind
doch fast Altersgenossen wir haben sie
doch erlebt ein bisschen Waffen für eine
caragua gesammelt haben
wie die wieder Vietnamkrieg auf der
deutschen Straßen übertragen worden ist
es ist Herr Ströbele verstorben Gott
habe in seelig und ich mochte ihn auf
eine gewisse Art gerne aber der massiv
sich damals in diese
waffenlieferungsprogramme eingemischt
hatte
die Militanz im in der internationalen
Politik die hat sich dann gespiegelt in
der Art und Weise wie Sie sich auf
unserer Straßen aufgeführt haben also
sie hat auch immer
nein diese friedensstopp diese
friedensnummer nimmt euch keiner ab die
gab es nicht in echt noch in den 80er
Jahren ist aus Gründen der
propalästinensischen Unterstützung noch
in den 80er Jahren haben die Israelis
führenden grünen Politikern wegen der
Unterstützung von Gewalttaten der
Palästinenser die Einreise nach Israel
verweigert und insofern kehren Sie jetzt
damit mit ihren mit ihren
waffenlieferungspropaganda und
vernichtungsfantas mit Russland zu ihren
alten Wurzeln zurück
ich bin groß geworden
im Schoß der evangelischen Kirche mit
den ersten Schritten in der Ausbildung
und Vietnam war tatsächlich ja ein
großer Schock was dort den Menschen
zugefügt worden ist und das war ja nicht
nur in Deutschland so sondern das war
auch in den USA so und dieser Krieg ist
dann zum Glück ja auch viel zu spät
beendet worden
das was Herr Gauweiler beschreibt das
ist bei den Grünen einzelne gegeben hat
die für Waffen für extra cyber-dur
gewesen sind zum Beispiel Ströbele das
ist die haben sich auch nie als
Pazifisten bezeichnet übrigens aber der
große Teil derjenigen die 1980 und 83
gegen die Pershings auf die Straße
gegangen sind und die Grünen übrigens
immer gegen die SS-20 auch auch gegen
die russischen Atomraketen wir haben
gesagt diese atomare be ist
hochgefährlich und sie ist es ja auch
sie ist es ja auch es kann ja niemand
sind sie noch eine pazifistische Partei
heute die Grünen nein die Grünen sind
keine pazifistische Partei sie sind
übrigens das ist etwas was man in den
grünen selber auch noch mal diskutieren
muss mit dem gewaltfrei mit diesem Bein
gewaltfrei haben sie nie den Pazifismus
bezeichnet sondern sie haben sich gegen
diejenigen abgegrenzt die bei
anti-akademonstrationen gewalttätig
geworden sind diese Bewegung hat immer
gesagt wir üben keine Gewalt aus das war
die Gewalt klingt das logisch für Sie
Wiener wie Frau Blatt darf ich sagen das
ist das ist das ist die glatte
Unwahrheit was wir gerade gehört haben
und dann weiter in der Runde das genaue
das genaue Gegenteil ist richtig die
Grünen haben massiv zur Gewaltaktionen
nicht mehr aufgerufen sondern massiv
daran beteiligt erzeuge Joschka Fischer
der als Straßenkämpfer in Frankfurt
ja mit verwickelt war
was heißt nicht als grüner das ist eure
Symbolfigur jetzt habe ich umsonst
massiv massiv in Gewalttaten und weil
sie dir es ist 20 Proteste angehen die
sind Angesicht sie sind angeführt worden
von dem die sind angeführt wann von dem
General Bastian der seine
Lebensgefährtin Petra Kelle erschossen
gleichzeitig rückwärts gewandt deswegen
noch einmal
überhaupt nicht mehr hören ist das für
sie logisch andere sagen und noch ein
letztes Mal Frau Wagenknecht das ist
heuchlerisch
naja ich persönlich sage in der
Situation ist es natürlich
nachvollziehbar und wir als Union treten
ja auch dafür ein dass wir der Ukraine
in dieser Situation helfen und helfen
können in dieser Frage ja ich weiß nicht
ob ich jetzt verantwortlich dafür bin
wie die Grünen das begründen ich sage
wie wir dazu stehen und natürlich wissen
wir streiten aber heute einfach über die
Grünen was ich persönlich was ich
persönlich mal gedacht habe auch in
früheren Jahren wenn wir dann auch immer
gesagt haben naja wir brauchen auch
natürlich eine funktionierende
Bundeswehr wir brauchen da auch
Waffenlieferungen im Gebiete wo es
schwierig ist dann ist schnell auch der
moralisierende Zeigefinger aber nehmen
Sie das zum Beispiel Anton Hofreiter ab
so wie Waldemar hat man das gerade
geschildert hat Panzer Toni sagt
waldemar Hartmann nehmen Sie das den
Grünen ab sind die glaubwürdig in dieser
Frage jetzt für Waffenlieferung in die
Ukraine also ich halte das schon für
glaubwürdig ich glaube was ja auf
Freitag da sagt das meinte auch so der
Wechsel von einer Partei die ja für ganz
andere Dinge eingetreten ist Frieden
schaffen ohne Waffen ja das war ja nun
für viele Jahre auch tatsächlich das
Auto
aber das ist nicht nur seit der Zeit so
dass der Wechsel jetzt ist schon
bemerkenswert und der ganze Wahnsinn ja
angefangen die Rahmenbedingungen würde
ich auch jedem zugestehen dass er sich
in seiner Haltung ändert aber der
Wechsel ist schon bemerkenswert und ob
es dann glaube ich ist das wird man dann
in der Zeit auch sehen vor allen Dingen
dann aussehen wenn andere wieder
Regierungsverantwortung tragen und wie
sich dann die Grünen darzustellen es
geht um moralischen Kompass es geht um
Glaubwürdigkeit passt das für Sie dazu
den Hamburger Hafen sie sind aus Hamburg
an die Chinesen zu verkaufen
ganz anderes Thema das ist ein anderes
Thema aber es passt zu moralischen
Kompass ja selbstverständlich passt es
zum moralischen Kompass also man muss
man muss klar sagen wir haben immer mit
China Handel geführt china ist ein
wichtiger Handelspartner und
gleichzeitig ist es Sie wissen sie
werfen
seit Minuten sie sind nur sogar noch
dran aber sie werfen seit vielen Minuten
der anderen Seite der Union vor und zu
abhängig gemacht zu haben von russischem
Gas und sie stritten eine neue
Abhängigkeit dort überhaupt nicht in
irgendeiner Abhängigkeit jetzt ein
mit den Chinesen wenn der Hafen verkauft
wird
nicht es wird nicht der Hafen verkauft
es werden aber sie haben damit eine
Sperrminorität sie haben damit eine
sperminität da wird ein großer Einfluss
der Chinesen vielleicht ja vorweg
schicken dass ich sehr kritisch bin ich
bin sehr kritisch es gibt ernsthafte
Bedenken verschiedener für
Sicherheitsfragen zuständige Ministerien
ich hoffe dass die auch entsprechend
berücksichtigt werden diese Bedenken
gleichzeitig ja aber die Entscheidung
die liegt jetzt beim Bund ja aber sie
können Streit machen sie könnten beim
Bund ja und aber am Ende ist es so wie
bei der akw-frage mit dem dritten am
Ende wird Machtwort gesprochen im
Kanzleramt wieder von Herrn Scholz und
sagen Sie für uns ist okay man muss also
erstmal die Lage sich angucken wir sind
in allen möglichen Wirtschaftszweigen
ganz ganz eng verbunden mit China über
alle Bereiche hinweg das müssen sie auch
glaube ich als Wirtschaftspolitiker ist
es nicht mehr gesund also ich muss sagen
und auch das sollte uns mit Sorge
erfüllen wenn ich China jetzt frei waren
angreifen sollte und wir dann mit
Sanktionen kommen dann haben wir ein
riesengroßes Problem ein riesengroßes
Problem und zwar überall nicht nur über
den Hafen deshalb sagen und das Problem
sehr größern sie doch gerade in Hamburg
vor Berg ich würde mir wenn ich den Satz
noch sagen darf ich würde mir wünschen
dass wir hier auch stärker europäisch
agieren auch mit den europäischen Hilfen
zusammen denn wenn man sich anguckt wie
cosco sich eingekauft hat in andere
europäische Häfen angefangen von Piräus
zu 100 Prozent in Rotterdam und
verwerten dann sollte uns das sehr
sorgenvoll stimmen und das ist auch
meine Sorge im Moment und dennoch habe
ich die Entscheidung jetzt gerade nicht
teile das sehe ich glaube die Lektion
was für hohe Kosten das macht sich von
Russland so abhängig zu machen diese
Lektion muss jetzt übertragen werden auf
unser Verhältnis zu China keine
Geschäfte
aber ich entschuldige
Wirtschaften glob Wirtschaften sind
hochkomplex da kann man nicht sagen ab
morgen hören wir auf Kontakt zu haben
aber man muss strategisch denken und da
sind solche Fragen bitte das tun die
Chinesen genau die Chinesen tun ist sehr
und ich glaube dass wir gut beraten sind
also aus der Lektion eines
schlussvordergrund zu ziehen ich habe
jetzt Reporter viele Unternehmen besucht
die von chinesischen Firmen übernommen
wurden und da am Anfang war das immer
gut inzwischen hat sich die Lage gedreht
und wenn man sich anguckt was in China
passiert ist gerade also China steuert
keinen guten Kurs an und wir sollten
einfach nur das nicht man kann Stopp
machen und aber wir sollten das Risiko
nicht noch vergrößern und wirklich das
genau prüfen was dort passiert bei
diesen Investitionen denn die ich lesen
würden ist umgekehrt übrigens auch tun
aber natürlich brauchen wir China als
Handelspartner das ist ganz klar
viele Unternehmen
auch von den Grünen diesen Pragmatismus
diese strategische Denken jetzt hat ein
total pragmatischer grüner gestern
überragend eine Wahl gewonnen im
Tübinger Rathaus nämlich dieser Mann
hier Boris Palma der danach auf dem
Rathausplatz tanzt ja eine absolute
Mehrheit hat er errungen dort als
Bürgermeister und das zum dritten Mal
hätten sie ihn gewählt Frau Beck ja sie
hätten also nicht die grüne Kandidatin
gewählt vor Ort
dass uns ein so
unabhängiger Kopf auch wenn er manchmal
ärgerlich ist und ich habe Differenzen
mit ihm trotzdem finde ich dass er uns
gut tut frau Fegebank teilen Sie das ich
weiß nicht wie ich gewählt hätte wenn
ich jetzt in Tübingen wahlberechtigt
gewesen bin sie wollen ja raushaben aus
der Partei sie haben ihn immer wieder
kritisiert in ihrer Partei haben immer
wieder auf ihn drauf gehauen bei jeder
Interview Äußerung bei manchen ganz
besonders ändert sich das jetzt holen
sie ihn zurück das kann ich nicht sagen
das Verfahren läuft die volksbaden ich
finde das verdient Anerkennung und
Respekt dieses Ergebnis und es zeigt
dass er über viele Jahre wirklich
exzellente Kommunalpolitik gemacht hat
er hat man hat er so gepunktet weil er
im Grunde gegen die Parteien anti-grüner
ist oder weil er ist kein Wunder ich
glaube man sagt ja immer bei
Oberbürgermeisterwahlen aber auch selbst
bei Landtag zahlen das sind auch die
Personenwahlen und dabei
Oberbürgermeister ist es ganz deutlich
so denn die Tübinger mögen den der hat
dort was auf die Füße gestellt und ich
glaube den prägen Schwaben gefällt es
sogar wenn der ab und zu mal auf dem
putzhaut gegen die Gründe er ist Ökologe
also ein anti-grüner ist Unfug ihn als
anti-grün zu zeigen der Flüchtlingsfrage
total gegen sie gelaufen genau deswegen
ist er nicht ein anti-grüner sondern er
ist überzeugter Ökologe auch in seinem
Lebensstil und ich glaube
ich will ihn nicht raus haben also
insofern sie kennen sich mit Populismus
habe ich schon am Anfang gesagt so
wunderbar aus und haben das nie als
Schimpfwort begriffen ist Herr Palma ein
richtig guter grüner Populist und die
schneiden sich ins eigene Fleisch wenn
sie in der rausschmeißen
ja auf jeden Fall
vor allem ist ja ein unabhängiger Mann
er ist nicht dieser Typ Nick Esel der
bei allen Parteien so verbreitet ist
sondern rührt sich hat unabhängige
Ansichten und ist vor allem nicht
politisch nach einer Seite einseitig
gelähmt ja was was den Leuten immer
diese schlaganfallhafte gibt
ist der hat der das der sagt manchmal
Rechte Sachen dass seine Leute entsetzt
sind dann kommt er mit ganz linken Ideen
daher aber jedes Mal hat ein Konzept und
es ist jedes Mal durchdacht und ich
finde den gut sind sie das ist ein
bisschen der Vorwurf der mitschwingt zu
verspannt um jemanden zu ertragen
mittlerweile Frau Beck kennt da noch
ganz andere Zeiten ganz andere
Parteitage früher von den Grünen sind
sie zu verspannt das ist nicht mehr
ertragen jemanden wie Boss palman den
eigenen Reihen zu haben
er ist schon jemand der wirklich auch
stark polarisiert hat mit vielen
Äußerungen auch vielen Positionierungen
ich fand diesen Weg der da gegangen
wurde auch ein bisschen schwierig weil
ich gesehen habe wie erfolgreich wie
beliebt er in Tübingen ist über die
ganzen letzten Jahre und er hat da
richtig was gerissen und
gerade mit dem Gedanken mit ihr haben
wir diese Sendung begonnen eine eigene
Partei zu gründen am Ende Mittwoch ist
Palma
glaube ich nicht nein nein das ist
einfach das halte ich für ausgeschlossen
warum sind sie sich so sicher weil Boris
Palma manchmal der hafersticht so würde
ich das sagen so wie sein Vater übrigens
der war der Rebell vom remskreis dafür
schwer bezahlen müssen so also in ihnen
sticht der Hafer aber wenn es dann
ernsthaft wird ist der Kompass von Boris
Palmer belastbar da bin ich mir ganz
sicher und Sarah Wagenknecht noch mal
will uns raus aus der Natur will das
transatlantische Verhältnis
kippen sie sagt wir führen Krieg gegen
Russland und schützt damit die russische
vernichtungs- und
angriffspolitik also ich finde schon
dass die Unterschiede jetzt hier doch
noch mal klar wir haben heute Abend mit
ihnen hart mit den Grünen und hat über
die Grünen gestritten auch sie
erhartmann und gleichzeitig haben wir
sie erwischt wir müssen ihnen Foto
zeigen und sie müssen erklären wie bitte
schön passieren konnte wir sehen sie auf
einem Bild und Seite an Seite mit dieser
Frau was da passiert also das ist jetzt
ein volles gibt noch viel schönere
Claudia kommt aus Augsburg ich habe da
zehn Jahre gewohnt und sie ist eine
absolute fußballfachfrau mit der ich
darüber schon oft diskutiert habe die
hat auch beim FCA den Stefan Reuter
schon zusammen geputzt wenn sie der
Meinung war der hat den falschen gekauft
oder den falschen verkauft also gucken
sie gemeinsam Fußballweltmeisterschaft
ja ich schaue natürlich
Fußballweltmeisterschaft in Katar ich
weiß nicht wie Claudia das macht aber
das Schönste war es gibt in Bayern einen
Bekannten faschingsorten da heißt der
schlappmaul unten und den hatte Claudia
bekommen
noch nie etwas schöneres über mich
gesagt worden wie von Claudia Roth was
muss passieren damit sie in ihrem Leben
jetzt mit 74 doch noch mal irgendwann
die Stimme hier drüben den grünlein
also leicht Stimmen habe ich noch nie
gemacht ich habe es Überzeugung gewählt
weil aus leichtem ist immer nur Unfug
entstanden und das wird nicht passieren
ich werde mit Kaffee gebaut ja wir gehen
wir gehen gerne mal zur Werder Bremen
ihren Lieblingsverein und ich erkläre
sie über alte Zeiten von Werder auf die
ich mitgemacht habe
das waren übrigens habe ich damals
immer begrüßt 8 mein Trainer aus der
sozialistischen Volksrepublik ganz
einfach mit einer Forderung wäre ihre
grüne Stimme von Herrn Hartmann sicher
mit Weißbier für alle danke für diese
Rolle danke danke
Katharina Fegebank Marie Luise Beck und
danke an den kapitalschefern Horst von
Buttler danke Peter Gauweiler wir sind
nächsten Montag zurück um 22:15 Uhr hier
bei Bild danke